foreign
welcome to the minimalist podcast where
we discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua Fields Milburn and I'm Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists we've got malabama here hi
everybody TK Coleman it's a beautiful
day it is indeed the rest of our team is
here in the studio as well coming up
today on this free public minimal
episode we're talking to a listener
about psychological clutter and we've
got a very special guest to help us
tackle this question then we've got our
lightning round segment a live stream
question and a listener tip for you you
can check out the full two hour maximal
edition of episode 393 where we answer
five times the questions and we dive
deep into several simple living segments
that private podcast episode is out
right now at patreon.com the minimalist
so your support keeps our podcast and
YouTube Channel 100 advertisement free
because advertisements suck let's start
with our callers if you have a question
or a comment for our show give us a call
406-219-7839 or email a voice recording
to podcast at the minimalists.com our
first question today is from Jess
hi my name is Jess and I'm from Sydney
Australia what do you think is the
anatomy of Hope could it be an idealist
trigger for accumulating psychological
clutter or a psychological clutter
perhaps caused by our ego's response to
hope not actually hope itself
I tend to believe that hope is born out
of the ego's response to rules and
exceptions and so when we look at a
situation that is very unlikely to
happen there is an initial unconscious
impulse to logicize and call in the
statistics
we seem to have this desire to seek out
and become aware of how many of our
peers have attempted to do this before
us and failed and we grow increasingly
convinced of the circumstantial
resources these unforeseen forces of
luck and chance that always seem to be
this uncontrollable part of the process
in making something happen
so we read the failure stories and our
mind implores us to stop there being
that our subconscious mind considers
comfort in what is known as synonymous
with safety and assurance
at a certain point it seems that the
risk has surpassed its worth the safety
is exceedingly compromised as the
unconscious would perceive it and would
become all too aware that if one can
fail the next one can too and that can
be us
I think becoming aware of how many have
held a similar dream and lost it along
the way is probably one of the most
devastating causes behind the build up
of emotional and psychological clutter
it is often a case of why was I so
foolish why did I hope so much for
something different versus why was I so
fearful why didn't I have enough hope
interestingly in the book The Art of
thinking clearly rafter belly talks
about something called survivorship bias
where he says that in daily life because
Triumph is made more visible than
failure we systematically overestimate
our chances of succeeding
although I understand this as a concept
I think it completely overlooks the role
that Hope plays in these experiences so
I'd love to get your thoughts on where
you find Hope in the midst of
psychological clutter and how do you
balance hope and pragmatism in a world
where they're often pitted against each
other
joining us in the studio to help us
answer this question and many other
questions on the private podcast is our
good friend Dr John Delaney ladies and
gentlemen
[Applause]
you can take your hand off my leg under
the table my hands are above the table
video proves it Dr J so John I want to
talk to you about this because I think
Ryan TK and I all have a sort of
different understanding of Hope and I
want to kill the sacred cow here kill it
I think what happens quite often is
there are two types of hope there's one
kind of hope that is really just an
expectation that's dressed up in a
tuxedo oh I really hope I win this
Championship I really hope this person
gives me their phone number I really
hope I win this game I really hope I
make this amount of money I really hope
I get this promotion I hope I get the
things the material possessions that
make me happy I hope I get the status I
hope I get the friends I hope I get the
career whatever it is these are just
expectations right and we think as
though they're going to complete us or
make us more full more sad satisfied
fulfilled but the opposite often happens
and so I think there's a bit of
psychological clutter here that is often
created by that kind of hope now there's
another kind of hope uh Desmond Tutu I
wrote this down he said hope is being
able to see that there is light despite
all the darkness
now that kind of hope is like an
optimism a hopefulness right and so when
people hear me talk about Hope and say
it's not maybe it's not as virtuous as
we always hold it up in this light as
though it's always good it's always
helpful it is always this Beacon of
light maybe sometimes it is when you see
that there is a lot of darkness and yet
there is some light there however
sometimes hope creates this
psychological clutter when we have so
many hopes as Jess illuminates here all
of a sudden we have this you know
there's a psychological clutter that
sort of exists at the intersection of of
mental clutter and emotional clutter and
on your show the John deloney show which
we'll link to in the show notes you talk
to a lot of people about anxiety and I
think a lot of our anxieties actually
have to do with these expectations that
were were renaming hope I consider there
to be a stark difference between a wish
and hope and wishes that's what you're
talking about earlier with expectations
and they're ungrounded they're unfounded
there's no there's no everything's
attached to it right versus
I like the idea of Hope as Desmond says
it's a path forward right it's it's a
we're heading towards a thing
um and yeah those are radically
different constructs because when you
have a path there's usually some
confidence you usually you you've you've
been with somebody or you have taken
steps towards a Thing versus I'm just
sitting here hoping to be fulfilled
externally right yeah well that's
another quote that I had written down
from Arthur Miller I think it's a
mistake to ever look for Hope outside of
one so yeah
um
yeah hope is uh it's almost like hope
based off of impulse becomes a wish I
mean I'm I guess certainly there are
impulsive hopes that might be something
that gives you that light but yeah it
seems like the hope that you're talking
about is based off of this um impulsive
desire we want something right now yeah
interesting it's this is the first time
I've heard you talk about Hope and I
wasn't like oh I gotta throw something
in there
like it's I really like how you
described it so do you do you do you not
like hope it's not I don't like or
dislike I think of like material
possessions people often think like Ryan
TK and I are against material
possessions right and then so when I
start to talk about Hope one might
Intuit from that that I dislike hope no
I think hope can be really useful for
someone being hopeful being optimistic
not blindly optimistic though not
blindly hopeful but quite often just
like our material possessions can get in
the way of our space and they can also
create mental and emotional clutter I
think hope can often do the same thing
hoping for all of these externalities to
happen it's a type of consumerism
consumerism is saying hey if I get that
thing it's going to make me happy or
make me complete well the same thing is
true with hope in fact isn't that a type
of Hope in a way it is a wish as you
call it and we often use these terms
synonymously right and so when I say
wish or I say hope we often mean the
same thing I hope I get that which is
fine but if I'm going to make myself
miserable until I get it well that's
psychological clutter yeah and it can
become a numbing device right and
um can be a way of pausing your day by
sitting there and just wishing I had and
wishing I had and wishing I had
um what I want us to guard against is
Amos taversky
um a famous psychologist says and I'll
I'll butcher the quote up but he said
being pessimistic is a waste of time
because if it comes true
it's happened twice once when you
imagined it and meditated on it and once
when it actually happened so why not
spend your energy hoping for why not
spend your energy
um pouring into the best possible
outcome and and heading that way and I
think when you again it for me it's
about momentum and it's about movement
instead of just sitting there trying to
accumulate right yeah um one of those
becomes an anchor yeah I mean it's a
tool right that's what hope is and we
have to be careful how we use it yeah
yeah it's similar to Faith if we think
about faith as the willingness to bet on
something or someone or as the
willingness to act in accordance with
what we say we believe it's like is
Faith good or bad well it kind of
depends who or what are you placing your
faith in who or what are you trusting in
and there are some people you can trust
some processes you can trust that will
really damage you and hurt you that
doesn't mean trust is bad it just means
we can't hide behind these Concepts we
can't hide behind advice and say oh I
found a neat little concept I found a
cool little word a cool little Maxim and
I don't have to think critically anymore
I can just sort of hide behind that no
trust hope faith love all these things
can destroy you if you Channel those
energies in the wrong direction or if
you have as the object of your hope or
your faith something that is not worthy
of it but all of these things can be
tremendously life-giving as well
depending on how you direct those
energies or in whom you place that trust
yeah
that's the anatomy of hope I guess
podcast over great job TK
so
I guess go back to her question
what is the anatomy of Hope hmm like if
you can if you look at it geometrically
what is that what does that look like
yeah yeah it depends what kind of hope
you're talking about right if you're
talking about the the freedom that you
experience to me it doesn't require hope
and that's
when someone asks a question like this
it almost presupposes that one must have
hope in order to fill in the blank
succeed be happy whatever it might be
but I can tell you many of the things
that I've accomplished throughout my
life all of my so-called most impressive
accomplishments are never things that I
hoped would happen they were a byproduct
of doing something that didn't actually
require hope when I write every day I
sit down in the chair put words on the
page there's not a outcome necessarily
in mind right and even if there is an
outcome in mind an arrival point I don't
have to hope that I get there when I
drove from Ojai down to La I don't hope
that I make it there I just simply draw
and hope isn't part of that process at
all for me but I am hopeful as I do it
right and I think that's the distinction
I like to make if I if I have to in if I
have to inject hope it's sort of the
opposite of what you were saying right
but yes being pessimist stick I'm I'm
not pessimistic at all in fact I'm often
accused of being overly optimistic but
yes I think with hope it's the same
thing being hopeful right now is not
required for me to get to my destination
hmm that's interesting because no one
would look at someone who's like has
hope all the time and be like that's a
really hopeful person it almost sounds
like an insult or um like you would feel
sorry for that person like oh
interesting yeah but you would look at
someone and be like that's a really
optimistic person yeah so um there was a
monk that I credit with uh really being
um important state in my life a decade
ago and he was a bioethics professor and
then at the end of the semester he'd
head off to the monastery and be gone
until school start again and I remember
one day we were having lunch and he told
me John pessimism and sarcasm are the
wisdom of this age and they so often
present as wisdom and joy and hope and
optimism so often present as nonsense as
the idiot right and he said never forget
that those are that that's just an ethos
and you can over time change your
default setting to one of optimism one
of one of okay here's all the challenges
let's go get it versus here's all the
challenges let's shut it down yeah yeah
yeah and I think that's the getting back
to the Desmond Tutu quote like if there
are a bunch of challenges there that's
where hope is a useful tool right it's
saying yes I know I can get to the other
side of these challenges that are in
front of me or someone who is in
tremendous debt or having mental health
issues as we'll talk about later today
no matter where you are if you have
challenges in front of you maybe it is
that kernel of hope that allows you to
realize like oh this is something I can
either get through get around Bypass or
let go of altogether and yeah it's it's
man it's not using hope as Xanax it's
just sitting there not not willing to do
anything and engage and just say I hope
I hope I hope I hope yeah
um and I think it's also important to
note
sometimes those in our community are the
light switch right
um I can spend time with you and I can
see hope that oh I can do better when it
comes to this stuff or I can spend time
with Ryan and think I don't want my
marriage to look anything like I'm just
kidding but you can be around other
people and they are hope because they
they are the path you can see them and
go okay that's an example of what this
looks like for me yeah yeah they're
shining the light for you which gives
you that intrinsic sense of hope you're
not you're not relying on them you're
witnessing that I have a picture of it
now exactly yeah yeah well speaking of
Hope and tying that into anxiety really
quickly
um you talk to me privately off off mic
but I'm going to drag it here on like
you just finished writing a new book
that comes out in October
building a non-anxious life okay and
going through this you also realize you
had to go rent a hotel room to finish
the book and then when you got home you
said oh wait there's a lot of anxiety in
my own life and it has a lot to do with
my material possession yeah so I I
started with a couple of premise one is
um and again I'm considering myself a
mental health professional that's what I
do and that's my community and more
people than ever before are medicated
more people than ever before are under
the care of a professional and the
depression and anxiety rates continue to
Skyrocket and I remember thinking when
when they discovered penicillin
deaths from infection fell off a map
right and so what we're doing might be
an adjunct might be helping we're not
solving this problem we've got to look
at some of these things at a deeper
level so that's where I started with the
premise and I went down a rabbit hole to
try to figure this out and as we were
talking last night
I couldn't deny the the literature and
just my own life about anxiety and stuff
and having bodies designed for scarcity
suddenly surrounded by all this junk and
even if it's quote unquote good job and
I can't breathe yeah and I was
surrounded by all this debt and all of
this I'm hurt that we're absorbing
through the news all the time we're just
not designed for it and what I found
myself which is unique for me because I
consider myself a problem solver and
let's go
I didn't have a map out and I remember
leaving my family I got two young kids
and my wife and uh we live out in the
woods and I went checked into a hotel
for a week and said I gotta write my way
out of this I didn't know what to do um
in fact I even I even thought about
calling you guys being like hey man I
need some help here but I didn't have a
path out and it was
I thought I was out of the Matrix and I
realized oh no I was just in a different
version of The Matrix and the only way
to unplug from this thing is to get
completely out
um
yeah it's fascinating because what we
often think we should get
the object of our desire
quickly becomes the object of our misery
and we start to feel hopeless
when we get all of the things and it
didn't do what we thought it would do
and you just spin faster yes yeah yeah
it's funny because uh we do a home tour
every week on patreon for our video
podcast subscribers and a few weeks ago
I posted a photo of where I live and I
just I was literally walking through the
house snapped a photo real quick because
I knew I needed to post it up something
up on patreon and it was and it's
aggressively simple but I didn't like
tidy up or anything it's rather
brutalist it's Stark right I'm not
prescribing that to anyone but I
remember the first comment was yeah like
anyone lives like that
I was like well wait a minute but that's
exactly how I live you're like where are
you hiding all of your stuff I'm like I
got rid of it
and my actual response was if it was on
social media I would just ignore it but
it was one of our patrons and my
response was you don't have to hide your
stuff if you get it out of the way right
I don't think the stuff is is bad or
wrong or evil but if it's creating this
underlying anxiety ultimately what
happens is that anxiety
just like if you were to hear sirens
going by constantly that's going to
create anxiety within you loud noises
visual clutter creates this internal
clutter in our lives and what was the
best way for me to get on the other side
of that was to subtract anything that
was actually covering up the path for me
so um and I didn't write about this this
first time I've talked about this
publicly my wife
um
one day I was down in the gyms over
Christmas and we have a little gym in
our our basement and I'm exercising down
there and she heard me cheering and I'd
gotten a text message this was over the
holiday break that I landed a speaking
gig that I really wanted and the guy who
runs all that for me he had texted him
and said hey and I think we got you
another one and I was cheering so she
comes down and says what are you so
excited about and I was like I got this
and then I got this and if she retells
this she said I literally was watching
my husband die in front of me and then I
hear him cheering that he got more work
and her her normal she withdraws right
so when she gets upset or gets anxious
her normal move is to just pull back and
then we reconvene and this time she
didn't and she stepped forward in a way
that kind of caught me off guard and
I'll never forget this as long as I live
because it was unmooring she said the
pie chart that is how much I love you
and the pie piece that is how much money
you make is full
anything that you go get Beyond this
is not for me and it's not for the kids
it's for your ego and she said so from
this point forward go do whatever you
want to do but do not make the mistake
of thinking it's for us and then she
said this John we have enough and then
she walked out and I remember thinking I
don't have a psychology for the word
enough I didn't know where to go and I
took the jobs I took both of them
because I didn't I didn't have it I
didn't have another path and now I'm on
this like I'm literally in real time
what does enough mean what does enough
mean because I got one set of part of my
brain being screamed at if you don't
have this if you don't have this
literally the world's coming down
money's gonna go away the econ this is
democracy's running around so you got
this and on the other side I've got a
body design for scarcity it's like I
can't handle it and it's like my body
declared Civil War on itself and I it's
uh it's what is enough what is enough
right before we even unpacked the enough
part I just gotta shine a spotlight on
this and say ladies and gentlemen this
is what greatness looks like yes this is
what greatness looks like this is why
you're great at what you do and think
about that Infamous moment we're in the
middle of a game Jordan does a move on
Kobe and when there's kind of like a
break and play Kobe goes up to Mike gets
next to him and says how did you do that
and I thought that's what greatness
looks like because he's not saving faith
in this moment he's being a humble
student of the game and saying hey I I
don't really know something can you can
I just put off the competitive mask for
a second and have you teach me and what
you're doing I always say that a teacher
is just a lead learner they are there to
model for their students what it looks
like to learn and I think being a mental
health practitioner you got to be your
first client in order to be good at
helping other people and to see you
process in real time to see you wrestle
with your own vulnerabilities and to say
look I don't always have to look like I
know the answer to everything that's why
you're so freaking great man and it
gives people perspective this right here
it's a huge hit well yeah I mean in that
same vein I want to point out like how
you're modeling um a good relationship
man the fact that like you and your wife
can have interactions like that and uh
become stronger from it and there's not
like a defense that comes up and you
really consider what she's saying it's
the same thing
um like when my wife comes to me and
says something uh you know a boundary
that I've crossed or that she hasn't
expressed you know my first my the old
Ryan Nicodemus my first reaction would
have been like oh well this is why you
shouldn't have that boundary because
here's why you shouldn't feel that way
and now it's um it's very much like yeah
like I I know that this woman loves me I
know that we're good for each other
um it's it's like if Josh came to me and
said something it's like I know that
Josh isn't coming at me with something
that um is an insult or you know he's
just you know out of his mind it's more
about like hey here's something I've
observed that that might help you and
it's I think in romantic relationships
it's harder to take it sometimes uh when
to take advice like that sometimes so
yeah awesome like modeling an amazing
relationship too I don't know how your
wife puts up with you but that's that's
awesome man she's pretty she's pretty
incredible man
you got off the elevator today we went
to a dinner together last night I don't
know how many people were there 70 80
100 people and um we're there and then
you got off the elevator this morning he
said when when did you leave last night
I don't remember what I said but I said
when I had enough yeah and when I had
enough was like what is enough for me is
different for Ryan and TK were still
there because they hadn't had enough for
them yeah right I still needed like two
more glasses
when they brought the disco ball out
tickets the first one on the floor man
my problem used to be that everyone else
is enough I then prescribed that to me
oh yeah yeah everyone else is working
this these many hours or they're
aspiring to be a c-level executive that
must be enough for me because it's
enough for that person not even a
knowing whether or not it actually is
enough for them they haven't stopped to
ask that question what is enough either
right but also I didn't stop to ask that
question what is enough money what is
enough time what is enough
accomplishments what is enough Twitter
followers what is enough friendships
what is uh what is enough in my life and
when I didn't ask that question more was
always the answer always I said that's
our culture's default narrative which is
more add ad
um I I and I guess there's a there's a
humbling part that I can't believe I've
made it this far in my life and I
without stopping to spend a considerable
amount of time
um both personally spiritually
psychologically with my wife what is
enough because if you don't man that
machine just I mean it just the arrow on
the on the treadmill just keeps getting
pushed and pushed and pushed and in this
in this world that we're at there's it's
it's the answer is never there's never
enough there's always somebody wants a
piece and I can't believe I spent this
much time trying to talk about mental
health and and without pondering that
question very deeply and some of that is
it's not so much a shortcoming in you
some of that is just evidence of the of
a great Marriage playing the role that
it's designed to play correct it's a
mirror of accountability right because
we have our own narratives where
sometimes our concept of enough is based
on the assumptions about what other
people expect of us it's kind of like
him Breaking Bad where he's made all
these sacrifices kind of ruined his life
looks at his life and says I did it all
for you and she says I never asked you
for any of this and it's like light bulb
on
you mean I was living out this narrative
based on what I assume you expected of
me yeah thank you for that gift right
and sometimes we do that and I think
what a wonderful gift your wife gave you
when she says we have enough and it sets
you free from any story you can tell
yourself about well my wife wants this
my wife needs that my family needs that
like nah man she just gave you in a
really amazing gift and so we when we
have those moments we can say ah why
didn't I know that earlier or it's like
thank God I know it
and that freedom can be untethering
right when someone just cuts that
balloon string
man there's some there's some floating
around yeah that happens before you kind
of reground but yeah it's good it's
difficult when it keeps phone in your
lap too man like when you um you have
enough but people are trying to give you
more work in this case I mean yeah of
course the default mode is yeah I better
take the shot because you know writers
and like what we do there is no salary
it's like you know you kind of got to
take which which you can get when while
you can get it and yeah it's difficult
to turn that stuff down so let's get
practical real quick before we wrap this
up you said you're feeling stressed out
about your stuff specifically that that
that's what you're saying off camera
yeah so um I sat down in my in my
basement I've got a little writing room
down there and I got all my guitars on
the wall and all there's several which
is insane
um twice a year exactly
um and I've got books
um I'm a former academic my wife was Dr
deloney long before I was and so we've
got books everywhere and it was funny I
started pulling them apart and that
literally channeled you too I was like
how would we do this
and guys I I hung my head in shame
because I was like an educated mental
health guy has to have these on this
shelf and I will read these and then
there was like no you won't you've got
10 more in the Amazon box on the front
porch and it was this oh my identity is
just woven through this library and that
was a I need to sit down and get some I
need I I'm entered into a space that I'm
tempted to call a character issue I
don't think it's that I need some skills
I need a set of skills I need a a road
map to follow here because what I'm
going to do is I'm going to get rid of a
bunch of junk and I'm gonna buy it all
back because I won't have dealt with the
issue I think that's ultimately what
happens quite often that's why you don't
hear the minimalists do here are the 67
ways to declutter your bookshelves
because yeah I can show you how to get
rid of all your books in fact I go in
your house and steal all your books and
now you're bookless but you just
re-clutter the the space I used to own 2
000 books and some of which I'd actually
read most of which I hadn't but I held
on to them because they made me look
really smart when people came over look
at all these books that he hopes to read
right and and so that type of Hope was
actually getting in the way for me
because it was like my identity gets so
tied up in these things so a few rules
boundaries we really call them that we
set up a few years ago we have this uh
free ebook that people who listen to
this they can download it's called the
minimalist rule book 16 rules for living
with less it's just the minimalists.com
just click on our resources page there
are a bunch of free resources you can
download including the minimalist
rulebook but a couple that I really find
useful in a scenario like this is the
spontaneous combustion rule you can pull
out any item so you grab look at all of
your books at once as one item for a
second if they all spontaneously
combusted
would you replace all of them
and if the answer to that is no then
okay that's a sign but the answer is yes
that's okay that means okay I'm going to
get some sort of value from them
hypothetically right or what I feel a
sense of relief if they spontaneously I
feel so good man
right and that is the sign if I would
feel good then it's obviously clutter
not just physical clutter but it's that
mental emotional psychological clutter
that we've been talking about the other
one we hold on to a lot of books why
just in case three most dangerous words
in the English language and because it
allows us to justify holding on to
anything it's a toxic relationships
holding on to a career that is not
fulfilling us and holding on to the
stuff and the status and the identity
that we're holding on to and so what
Ryan and I came up with over a decade
ago was the just in case rule anything
that I'm holding on to physical I can
let go of it if I'm holding on to it
just in case because I can replace it
for less than twenty dollars in less
than 20 minutes from wherever I am now
first it's like that's an incredible
rule of privilege you have to spend
twenty dollars every single time you no
you never have to use it right things go
down to just in case you never end up
and it allows you to get rid of tens of
thousands of Justin case items that are
causing it clogging up they're creating
all of that internal clutter starting
with the physical clutter yeah real
quick like when it when it comes to your
stuff stressing you out are you stressed
out because you're thinking about how
Josh and I would judge you if we were
over in your study or like like what's
stressing you out about it
um and guys I just lost his name um he's
a Japanese minimalist
um
just lost just lost his name Don Matson
um who's the goes by the minimal mom she
she put me on to him and he
had this conversation where he says
every inamin object in your house is
having a conversation with you whether
you know it or not and at first I was
like I don't care that sounds all hokey
yeah and then I realized my guitars are
always saying oh are you just done
playing music is that who you are now
are you or my books are like are you
gonna be stupid Forever am I I've got
clothes in my closet they're like wow
remember when you used to exercise and
you were actually in shape or just gonna
be fat dad now is that is that where
we're headed and then I've got other
clothes like everything in my the dishes
in the sink are like oh you're gonna be
that husband that just hates his wife
you can be that guy you're hoarding hope
it never but it's it's this
it was this light bulb that came on I'm
having 10 000 conversations at the same
time the The Woodworking stuff is like
oh you're never gonna build that
treehouse for your son are you and he's
gonna go to college and you're gonna
sure son will get to it Cats in the
Cradle it never stops and so it's really
almost pathologically almost like civil
I'm trying to shut the voices up yeah
and at some point I can't compete I've
got to hand some of this stuff out right
because it won't stop and if it were to
spontaneously combust the voice to stop
yes the voice should stop as well Brian
what time is it you know what time it is
it's time for the lightning round where
we answer your questions from Tick Tock
yes indeed you can follow the
minimalists on Tick Tock Instagram
Facebook and elon's Twitter at the
minimalist are we still on there I know
we're not verified anymore I don't
there's something about not having the
blue check that I love do you feel less
important or more important or just the
same I feel like I'm opting out of the
game ah which is nice the validation is
not external Eternal it is internal
although I hear if you have a blue check
you can edit your tweets and you get no
ads or fewer ads which is the compelling
reason to me and I cannot tell you how
many times I've tweeted something and
then just responds to it and it's like
Hey You misspelled this
or how about we both stay employed take
that down yeah I don't care about that
we don't have an advertisement exactly
we can't be canceled You're Gonna Cancel
it me you can't cancel us we're
canceling us
all right during the lightning round
this is where we each have 60 seconds to
answer your question with a short
shareable less than 140 character
response we call the minimal maxims we
put these minimal maximums in the show
notes over at the mentalists.com podcast
so you can copy and share our pithy
answers on social media we'll let John
go last week and think about his pithy
answer but we have a question here from
yashvi aren't you always going to have
to compromise something in a
relationship for love if that's the case
wouldn't every one be single forever
let's talk about this so compromise
before we put any time on the clock for
Ryan here
it seems to me that there are different
types of compromise when we refer to
compromise right so let's give Ryan some
time let him unpack this for us
all right uh my fifth answer is this
love inspires the desire to support not
sacrifice so when I when I read this
question I thought about my wife and I
and how
I love going out of my way for
um she had a women's retreat that she
went and did it was she had an amazing
time I had a it she was finished on
Sunday night at a flight on Monday
morning so she didn't think I was going
to be there for her you know and she was
totally okay with that but I saw it as
an opportunity like I know I'm gonna
lose sleep tonight but I'm gonna go up
there and like show her the support that
I know that she's really going to
appreciate and to me that wasn't a
compromise it wasn't a sacrifice it was
an opportunity for me to go up there and
really show how much I love her but like
set that aside set aside uh these
relationships I think about the other
day I was on the 405 and it was my
time's about up
I'm just gonna stop right there unless I
can get an additional 60 seconds all
right let's give them another 60 seconds
all right so I'm on the 405 the other
day and it's not it's not rush hour it
would have been better if it was rush
hour because at least traffic moves
slowly it was like lunch rush hour so a
lot of vehicles but
yeah going very very fast and as I'm
driving down the highway
um I see this kitten in the middle of
the road and I'm like oh my God this
kitten has like gotten hit and I start
to get sad and as I drive by it I see it
turn its head and you know you can tell
it's like meowing in my heart just like
melted I'm like oh man like I I have to
do something for this kitten so I like
pulled over
um and it was a perfect little spot uh
there was an on-ramp there's a little
median I get out of my car I'm like
waving like a madman like you know
stopping people I think Jordan you got a
picture of this you could put it up if
you want
um but I uh yeah waving like a madman
cars stop and just everything that I
compromise in that situation with like
my safety
um not just with the cars but diseases
from this cat like nothing was going to
stop me from like helping this cat out
and
um I saved it I'm a hero what can what
can I say
TK you got something pithy for me
uh yes relationships involve compromise
but compromise doesn't require
condescension so I give you my three C's
of compromise one catering two competing
three collaborating catering is when you
say well you don't want what I want we
don't like the same things but I'm gonna
Cater to You by stooping to the level of
your desire and I'll try to be insane
about it let's do what you want to do
competing is when you say well we're
going to fight each other to get the
other to bend to the will of the other I
want to do what I want to do you want to
do what you want to do but I'm going to
bend you in my direction and now we're
competing for who has the superior game
plan collaborating is when you say hey
it looks like my familiar habits don't
resonate with your familiar habits why
don't we work together to come up with
some new third thing that we both can
Delight in when you collaborate
compromise becomes an expression of
co-creativity rather than some form of
competition or catering that's what
makes a relationship life-giving you can
compromise without condescending yes
indeed let me I think I have a different
sort of idea about compromise what Ryan
was talking about earlier is he was able
to compromise his preferences for more
sleep without compromising his values
and I think that's what's important I
think that's what the question asked her
is conflating here you don't have to
compromise your values in order to love
someone love does not require compromise
it does not require commitment it does
not require Covenant it requires
awareness for the other person to love
someone is to see them for who they are
without trying to force them to change
without manipulating them without
persuading them without convincing them
that I know better than you I've got
this video real quick I want to play
from Anthony Demello that I thought
would fill us in here and better answer
this question than I'm capable of doing
love is like
listening to a symphony
life is a symphony
and to love means to be sensitive to the
whole of that Symphony it means to have
a sensitive heart
to everyone and to everything
you don't have to compromise your values
to have a sensitive heart to see someone
else yes if you're in a relationship
with anyone there are times where it's
going to be uncomfortable and it might
be your preference to be filled with
Comfort all the time you might have to
compromise some of your preferences
without compromising who you are as a
person
John any insights
I think I may contract all of y'all is
that okay yeah please I mean it's even
better we insist
when I Choose Love
I'm choosing to take a knee before this
other person
and say
I give you my all
and my hope is as we talked about
earlier my hope is you will reciprocate
that
but when I love I don't have to I get to
when I love I'm saying
I'm I I am putting all I am before you
and you now come first and when two
people do that together in a romantic
relationship and they both race to the
bottom of how can I love you how can I
love you how can I love you then
questions like that were asked they
become but amiss like they don't exist
there's no more like well I wanted to
watch that movie
I want to watch the movie that's going
to bring you the most joy and like if
you're with Ryan that's fast and the
furious seven and that's just what's
what he's into he's more of a Tokyo
Drift guy hey we're not friends we're
family we're family that's right but but
it's it's an ethos and does it always
work perfect no and there's there are
times you end up at family vacations of
course
um but I I just think it's a I think
feelings all that stuff is distant
nonsense too yeah I submit that's
exactly 280 characters we're good it's
amazing well you know when those
feelings come up like you know if Mariah
wanted to watch a movie and I'm like I
don't want to watch that movie why do we
always got to watch it with you like
that is a that is I mean I know that's
how you and your wife that's exactly how
we are but um but uh you know it's a
sign of something deeper like there's
always there is a deeper issue going on
if you're feeling resentment towards
something like
a movie preference
um there's probably some underlying
thing that you might want to dig into a
little bit and I think it's important to
call out what you mentioned about values
because there is going to be those
moments I want our kid to go to this
school I want our kid to go to this
school and love
just taking taking a knee doesn't solve
that issue right and so you've got to go
back to your values the ones you all
agreed on what you said TK you got to
build something new because you're
building it together right yeah we're
gonna check on with the patreon live
stream here in a moment but first real
quick for right here right now here's
one thing that's going on in the life of
the minimalists this is exciting because
we are one week away from our first ever
decluttering course we've been working
on this since last year it's called
simplify everything hopefully we'll get
Dr John do you want to be your first
person to tweet about it uh yeah I mean
here's here's the fascinating thing
about this we have resisted doing some
sort of course for a long time because
we know how much work goes into it I
teach a writing class online and I know
precisely how much effort you have to
put in to create something that's
meaningful that will bring immense value
to people's lives and so it it's these
five different areas of clutter so it's
five weeks long and we each each week we
help declutter one form of clutter it
starts with the physical clutter because
we're the minimalists and people often
associate material possessions with
clutter there's so many other kinds of
clutter that we unpack throughout the
course so the second week we walk you
through digital clutter the glowing
screens on your walls or in your pockets
or in your bag a lot of digital clutter
in our lives and then from there we go
to calendar clutter oh I'm so busy I'm
so bit that's just another way to say my
life is out of control when I say I'm
busy I'm busy I'm busy well how do we
get around that we declutter the
calendar clutter and from there we talk
about financial clutter we talk a lot
about the uh the yeah the the baby steps
and things like that you're like taking
chapter six of my new book man
congratulations like literally this is
it right here man but in the last while
the invitation is the best form of
flattering each copy somehow the the
last week we go through relationship
clutter the sort of toxic relations we
have in our lives or just some of the
relation issues that we are holding on
to because of convenience or proximity
that we might need to let go of and so
it's five weeks long it's 17 video
lessons each video Lesson I think has 14
different segments in it 45 clutter
problem areas 135 decluttering Solutions
a 30-page workbook student forums and
much much more of less
I'm so proud of this gentlemen like
looking at the videos uh we're going
through the editing process right now
and we really have provided something
amazing and Ryan called me yesterday he
goes I can't believe how great I was on
these videos
I'm like you stole the show week one
especially he was I mean just so on
point it was
57.6 game-winning shot it was
unbelievable if you're interested uh
simplify
everything.xyz is the website simplify
everything.xyz and this course opens for
72 hours only on May 29th but to go to
simplify everything.xyz right now put
your email address in there we'll let
you know as soon as the course the
enrollment opens up Alabama let's check
in with the patreon live stream what do
you got for us I have a comment here
from violet she says I think the
Japanese author Dr John deloney was
talking about earlier is fumio Sasaki
who wrote goodbye things excellent book
excellent yeah goodbye things which is
uh a book that we quoted from in our
last book A lot of people use things and
because the the idea is it's also it's
not just about like renouncing the
things it's almost honoring the things
by saying goodbye to them recognizing
that either you served a purpose you
added some sort of value or maybe I
thought you were going to but you're no
longer doing what I thought you would do
so goodbye yeah
we're gonna check back in with the
patreon live stream here in a bit but
first malibam what do you what else you
got for us here's the minimalist Insight
from one of our listeners hello this is
Bryce from Delray Beach Florida I wanted
to share a tip that I came up with to
live a more balanced and intentional
life
what I did was I have a planner that
instead of
going by the hour it goes by the
different Realms of Health
and it made this really cool acronym
that's easy to remember and easy to
apply and that's special
every day is special and every day is an
opportunity to grow spiritually
physically emotionally communally
intellectually
adaptively and lucratively all right
y'all that's our minimal episode for
today we'll see you on patreon for the
full two hour maximal edition of episode
393 which includes answers to a bunch
more questions like when is suicide that
is letting go of one's own life when is
that appropriate
what does an uncluttered mind feel like
what tips would you give somebody who
has trouble mentally clocking out of
work plus a million more questions for
Dr John deloney and the minimalists also
this week a private minimalist home tour
of one of our listeners bedrooms a
beautiful bedroom with beautiful
lighting all that much much much more of
less and if you want to check all of
that out check out the minimalist
private podcast at patreon.com the
minimalist or click the link in the
description to subscribe and get your
personal link so that our weekly maximal
episodes play in your favorite podcast
app you also get access to all of our
podcast archives all the way back to
episode zero zero one and if you're
still on the fence here's a testimonial
from one of our lovely patreon
supporters Tina says I just want to
share how the minimalist private podcast
has changed my life and why I continue
to support you on patreon I found your
podcast when I was in a dark place and
I've listened to almost every episode
thanks to your private podcast I have
healed my relationship with stuff my
house is orderly and I no longer desire
to buy what my neighbors own I don't
even shop for clothes anymore I already
have everything I need what I actually
needed was more time to be creative and
to connect with the people in my life to
love people
use things big thanks Tina that's a
really thoughtful comment really
grateful for the value that we are able
to add and also big thanks to Dr John
deloney for joining us today check out
his show it's on YouTube we'll put a
link to it in the show notes it's called
the Dr John deloney show and if you
leave here today with just one message
please let it be this
love people
and use things because the opposite
never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time peace
every little thing you think that you
need
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed or I bet that you'll
be fine without it foreign
foreign
every little